NFL players get fair value for the most
part for their services if players are
at games without fans in the stands what
does that mean for the NFL from a
dollars and cents standpoint Oh Forbes
had an item recently pegging the number
at five point five billion in losses far
more than I thought for the NFL thirty
eight of the total revenue gone when you
took take into account tickets and
Suites and parking and concessions and
everything that goes alright all of you
know you go to a game and it's 20 bucks
for this and 30 bucks for this and fifty
bucks for this and all that money flows
into the NFL coffers that's why you're
looking at five and a half billion Cris
if they have empty stadiums which tells
me at a minimum they're gonna find a way
to get some people into the stadiums and
in the states where they say fine by us
if people know the risks of the
coronavirus and they want to come to the
game let them fill the stadium up I
guarantee you there's going to be states
where they say hey you know the risk go
ahead to the game if you want to go to
the game that's right I mean I would
think a place like the Dallas Cowboys in
Texas right now that that might be one
of those places to do that you know and
you know again yeah you know the money
for the Suites and the concessions in
the parking it's huge it's huge for
these NFL owners you know but I'll say
hey you know to to to lose thirty eight
percent of your revenue hey it's better
than losing a hundred percent I'll just
say that and again we're we're all gonna
lose revenue this year I mean again just
to peel back the curtain you and I took
a pay cut it's just the way of the world
is right now I don't think anybody's
gonna sit there and go oh hey I'm gonna
make more money this year in the
pandemic year of Kolbe in nineteen and I
mean I guess there's probably a few
manipulators a wall street things like
that that will but for the rest of us
out here in the world and that in the
everyday working person they're gonna
lose money and they're not gonna want to
hear about like oh the owners they're
billionaires lost billions but still
made billions like so that's gonna go on
deaf ears to me and again I you know I
think that's it's still not horrible and
the big scheme of things is what I'm
saying the broader goal for the NFL is
going to be
make every penny that they can and write
the thing the the players are getting
their money the impact on the players
would come next year in the form of a
reduced salary cap if that even happens
the teams are going to have an incentive
to keep the salary cap high they've got
salary commitments into next year one
dynamic though and I don't want to get
too deep into the weeds we have the
story of PFT as to where the push and
pull may lie between the league and the
Union if there's no season at all and
it's academic at this point cuz there
will be a season I believe but let's say
they they think there's going to be a
season with sharply reduced revenues
because fans won't be at games I think
we could see a greater inclination to
dump that veteran who's making 7 million
and to roll the dice with a fifth-round
rookie because hey you know what we got
to reshuffle the budget here a little
bit and that guy that you know there
isn't that much of a difference after
training camp whatever training camp
they have I think we're comfortable with
this fifth round rookie and we could
save six seven million dollars by going
in that direction and I think those
considerations regardless of whether or
not you know we get to this point if
players getting full pay and they will
get full pay under the contracts but we
could see more contracts ripped up
before week one by teams that recognize
we need to save some cash yeah I think
that is a real possibility definitely I
think more this year than ever you could
see some cutthroat decisions like that
where yeah they wouldn't want to now the
big thing is you know and we talked
about this a little yester with Peter
King you know the fourth fifth six
rounders the undrafted free agents they
are really behind the eight ball and a
year like this you know Adam feeling
made that comment he doesn't know if
he'd make a team now at this day and age
but the way things are gone you don't
get that chance to prove to the coach if
you're a fifth round or to go hey look
at me I've done the right thing every
day you can trust me you can trust me
now there of course there will be those
guys that you can trust and training
camp to what you're saying and yeah if
they can build up that trust and go okay
you know we have a guy here making six
or seven million dollars and we got a
fourth or fifth rounder you know who hey
we actually he's done a really great job
in training camp and he's mature and
showed his work ethic he's not as good
as our seven
million dollar year player but it's not
a far drop-off yeah I think you could
see more cutthroat decisions like that
this year and there's another benefit to
that to the extent that you save six or
seven million in cash this year the cap
space you create now doesn't have to be
spent this year it automatically will
carry over to next year so if the set
you get a double whammy you save money
this year by going with the younger
cheaper guy and you can kick cap space
into next year in the event the cap goes
down you've got some flexibility because
you've got that extra six or seven
million you can throw onto the pile so
you don't have to maybe cut somebody you
really want to keep so I think this is
gonna be a real dynamic and it benefits
the veterans to have no offseason
program it benefits the veterans to have
a limited training camp you don't want
those young guys to prove themselves
this year this is the worst year for a
young guy to come in and show we can get
it done because it's more likely the
more expensive veteran is going to get
the heave-ho so the team that is looking
at games with no fans in the stands or
limited fans in the stands can save some
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports